I have never met a person who doesn't
like winning everybody I know loves
winning everybody loves winning matter
of fact my office it's filled with faces
who loved winning you know you got Tyson
here you got Tiger here you got Brady
here you got Jordan here you got George
Washington's autograph yeah bunch of
people here that are winners these are
guys who won these are guys who won at
the highest level but the one that I can
tell you about winning is that most
people are talking to a guy the other
day and this is kind of gonna get me to
the next one I want to talk to you about
is the guys coming up to me you saw me
you know I beat everybody and I'm doing
this and I'm doing I'm so great at what
I do and then I said against who though
he says what do you mean I said who are
you beating and he told me you was
beating I said you know what you're
doing is just what's that I said you're
only competing against people that are
below you you're not competing against
people that are above you because who's
really a threat tell me who you've
beaten and he says well how about this
person now you're not beating anybody I
said that's kind of like a senior in
high school bullying a 7th grader I said
what do you think about a senior in high
school
beating up a seventh grader what do you
call that a bully right there's anybody
respect the person now you're not
beating anybody that's worthy of
competition you're taking the easy way
out this is one of the reasons why
Muhammad Ali was so respected in the
game of sports and boxing because he
fought everybody at their peak at their
best
Foreman Norton Frazier at their best and
it's one of the biggest criticism
sometimes Mayweather would give because
he didn't fight [ __ ] at his best it was
a little bit later on who we fought so
what's the moral of the story look most
of us hate losing just as much as we
love winning
right but the moment losing becomes okay
and you tolerate losing losing becomes
accepted if it doesn't hurt anymore
you'll accept it and I'm talking in
anything if you're okay losing to you
becomes normalized okay it's not a big
deal it's okay it's okay it's okay
and I know this sounds strange because I
don't you ever ever seen the movie
Prefontaine it's the story of
Prefontaine there's a scene in the movie
with Jared Leto playing it and he's
running and in this one scene this kid
is about to be
and as I wait a minute you can't really
beat me in life but I'm gonna let you
beat me but um you can't really beat me
a lot to him it was almost like no no no
if I let this kid beat it's a
psychological Midway of me giving it now
I know historically when you read you
know and study animals and parents a lot
of times fathers or you'll hear certain
animals when their kid when their kids
are hitting them but you know they'll
act like it's hurting to make their you
know their son or their daughter feel
like they're stronger sometimes parents
do that all that hurts oh because the
kid is like so much I understand the
development process of building your
kids I get that but if you compete in
the marketplace and losing no longer
hurts it becomes a habit and once it
becomes a habit you don't just lose on
one area you start losing in every area
of your life because you're okay losing
now I'm not talking here about you know
well do you mean like every negotiation
I should lose or every negotiation I
should win and no matter what it is I'm
not talking about collaboration is at
the highest level I'm not talking about
you being okay to what I'm talking about
is you're growing your business okay and
you're going up against somebody and all
of a sudden you lose one time you lose a
second time you lose their time and
you're okay with it that mentality stays
here and it sticks it's a spirit and the
reads like the only time I remember one
time I lost I'll never forget this I
lost in a very ugly way and I got up on
stage and I got up on stage this was
2006 2007 I got up on stage and they
made me give the trophy to the other guy
remember till today I gave the trophy to
the guy and they said the loser has to
give the other person a message and I
got up and I gave the trophy very
honorable very easygoing I give it to my
congratulate the guy and I said
sometimes wish for something in this
year I said just want you to know
something he says what's that I said you
will never beat me for the rest of your
life never it's just not gonna happen
he says really I said you will never
beat me for the rest of your life I said
you're gonna have to kill me to beat me
it's just not gonna happen I don't like
losing and I lost that year because I
didn't work as hard that year I thought
I'd already like made it a sack all good
all this other never forgot was 26 27
years old
making some uh decent money here twenty
six twenty twenty six twenty seven
twenty eight years old and I got a
little bit cocky and I got caught and it
was great that it happened to me
phenomena that it happened to me but I
questioned myself
messiah's you feel right now bad you
okay with it yeah cuz you know most
people right after they lose over they
go to have a few drinks to kind of get
over it I internalized the pain I went
to my room looked at myself in the
mirror saying so PVD tell me you okay
with this you okay losing in front of
600 people
you just lost right now that's an ugly
it loss what are you gonna do about it
huh what are you gonna do about it
you're gonna be okay with it I came back
I started reading 1015 books a month I
started showing up to work six seven
o'clock in the morning staying up til
ten eleven o'clock eleven o'clock and I
work in a hundred hours so we can I said
this will never happen again
because I don't like to lose do I lose
all the time I lost today I lost last
week I lost last month all the time but
the only times I am okay it hurts a
little bit less is when I'm David and I
go up against collide in every
measurable category odds are against me
to win I'm not supposed to win cuz I'm
facing a Goliath not supposed to win
when I face a collide and I get close to
beating this guy and I tell myself oh
let me tell you what's around the corner
I can't beat these guys you're soon man
it hurts cuz it was so close a way to
see what's gonna happen next month or
next year or next quarter or three years
from now but I'm coming I'm coming and I
know this sounds crazy to some people
but it doesn't sound crazy to Roger
Federer or an adult or tiger or Brady or
Jordan or Kobe or magic or rock it
doesn't sound weird to these guys
because it's the wiring and you got to
think about that it's a very simple
question for you very simple question
for you how do you respond when you lose
are you okay with it and after you lose
do you just forget about it and move on
or do you come out as a whole different
person changing improving saying wait to
see what I'm gonna do next
no one knows that
only you know that because there's only
one person I can answer that question
and it's you and by the way if you watch
this video I got another video I want
you to watch is how to think big as an
entrepreneur if you've never watched it
click over here and go watch the video
how to think big as an entrepreneur
because it has a lot to do with today's
message have a killer week everybody
love you
bye bye